trying to uh
run a little bit more are you losing
weight I'm not trying to lose weight but
I always do the same Fitness routine
after like 30 years basically uh lift
three days a week run three days a week
um but one of the runs is the long run
one of them's medium one of them is a
Sprint type thing so
um what I've decided to do this year was
just extend the duration of the long run
and
um I like being a mobile I I never want
to be
um so heavy that I can't move like like
I want to be able to go out and run 10
miles if I have to so sometimes I do
um and I want to be able to Sprint if I
have to so sometimes I do and um lifting
in objects is feels good it feels good
to train like a lazy bear and just lift
heavy objects but I've also started
training with lighter weights and higher
repetitions and
um for three month cycles and it gives
your joints a rest and um yeah so
probably you know it I think it also is
interesting to see how training
differently changes your cognition
that's probably hormone related you know
hormones Downstream of training heavy
versus hormones Downstream of training a
little bit lighter
um I think my cognition is better when
I'm doing more cardio and when the
repetition ranges are a little bit
higher which is not to say that people
who lift heavy are dumb but there is a
because there's real value in lifting
heavy there's a lot of angry people
listening to this right now no no but
lifting heavy and then taking three to
five minutes rest is Far and Away a
different
challenge than running hard for 90
minutes
that's a tough thing just like getting
in an ice bath people say oh well how is
that any different than working out
um well there are a lot of differences
but one of them is that it's very acute
stress within one second you're stressed
so I I think subjecting the body to a
bunch of different types of stressors in
space and time is really valuable so
yeah I've been playing with the
variables in a pretty systematic way
well I like long and slow
for like you said the impact it has on
my cognition yeah it it uh the
wordlessness of it
um the way it puts you in in a the way
it seems to clean out the Clutter yeah
you know um it can take away that hyper
focus and put you more in a relaxed
Focus for sure well for me it brings the
Clutter to the surface at first like all
these thoughts come in there and then
they dissipate you know I've been uh
because I got knee barred pretty hard
that's when somebody tries to break your
nails yeah they try and break your knee
yeah because you tap so they yeah yeah
yeah so it's you know hyper extend they
need that direction the guy knee barred
pretty hard so
um in ways I don't understand it kind of
hurts to run I don't understand what's
happening behind there I need to
investigate this
it basically this the hamstring Flex
like curling your leg hurts a little bit
okay and that results in this weird doll
but sometimes extremely sharp pain in
the back of the knee so I'm I'm work I'm
I'm working through this anyway but
walking doesn't hurt so I've been
playing around with walking recently
like for two hours and thinking because
I know a lot of like
smart people throughout history have
walked and thought you have to like you
know play with things that have worked
for others not just to exercise but to
like integrate this very light kind of
prolonged exercise into a productive
life so they do all their thinking while
they walk it's like a meditative type of
walking it's it's really interesting it
really works yeah the um the practice
I've been doing a lot more of lately as
I walk while reading a book in the yard
I'll just Pace back and forth or walk in
a circle audiobook are you talking no
hard copy where you just holding I
holding the book and I'm walking and I'm
reading yeah and I usually have a pen
and I'm underlining I have this whole
system like underlining Stars
exclamation points goes back to
University of what things that will go
back to
um which things I export to notes and
that kind of thing
um but from the beginning when I opened
my lab at that time in San Diego before
I moved back to Stanford
um I would have meetings with my
students or postdocs by just walking in
the field behind the lab
um it you know and I'd bring my Bulldog
Costello yeah Bulldog Mastiff at the
time and he was a slow Walker so these
were slow walks but I can think much
more clearly that way there's a Nobel
prize winning uh professor at Columbia
University School of Medicine Richard
Axel who won the Nobel Prize coat one
Nobel Prize with Linda Buck for
Discovery the molecular basis of
olfaction and
um he walks in voice dictates his papers
and now with rev or these other maybe
there are better ones um than rev where
you can convert audio files into text
very quickly and then edit from there so
I I will often voice dictate
um first drafts and things like that and
um I totally agree on the long runs the
walks the integrating that with
cognitive work harder to do with Sprints
um and then the gym you know are you do
you weight train you just seem naturally
strong and like thicker jointed it's
true yeah it's true I when we did the
one very beginner because I'm a very
beginner of Jiu Jitsu class together
and um yeah as I mentioned then uh but
if people missed it uh Alexis freakishly
strong I think I was born genetically to
hug people oh like Costello exactly you
guys have a certain similarity he had
wrists like you know it's like you and
Jocko and Costello have these like
wrists and and elbows that are super
thick you know and then I mean you look
around you see tremendous variation you
know some people have like the the
um wrist uh width of a whippet or Woody
Allen and then other people like you or
Jocko or you know there's this one uh
Jocko video or thing on GQ or something
Have you seen the comments on Jocko
these are the best
um the comments I love the comments on
YouTube because occasionally they're
funny
um the best is uh when shock was born
the doctor looked at his uh parents and
said it's a man
like Chuck Norris type comments yeah oh
yeah those are great um that's what I
miss about Rogan being on YouTube with
the full-length episodes